guys you're looking a little bit
different tonight than you actually look
in spike island aren't you tell me about
getting that Madchester look Nadia I'm
not yeah just a sec she's just no she's
well she's a great makeup eyes and she
just like I mean the transformations
that she give us all you know like even
if they were little subtle things like
the other way you know your hair was
swept over the avoid the other side and
that was it
she was just brilliant with everything
like scheana she research research that
you know the 90s oh well and I mean we
had pictures all over the makeup talked
about what they look like in the nine is
and how kids would popping pills about
then and still you know things like I
just it makes it a little short
subtleties make it fun to work on you
know I mean and and that's what they did
for us they made it like a real joy to
work there you didn't think I'm gonna
keep those curtains that you know full
hair style look afterwards
gosh no that's yeah no not at all I was
a I had the curtains out of the vials
and now definitely not and the mushroom
like as well and the mushrooms all right
I see what you're laughing at all no but
good estate know to be honest listen I
think it's going to come back in the
mushroom at I personally think that this
90s look all the baggy jeans you know
the all the Adidas all that I think
that's coming I think I think would you
a new sort of twirl of life you'd be the
style leaders when it comes that were
you guys you were in all that's flubber
again to be honest I never had anything
adidas in my wardrobe after this by
Kylie don't don't ask him any questions
he's pathetic
I'm saying he's after I did it I went
and bought some adidas cobbler jammy
eyes doc oh oh there's something that
was ignorant about in the first place I
apologize for I'm sorry about ended uni
ago the influence of film you say what
guys what was it like filming in
Manchester well I mean we're off were
off sort of from in in RL Manchester and
it was just it was a real joy because
you got to go home and I picked up in
Manchester filming in places which you
know you drive past every day in it and
it's just like you see in people real
Manchester people on set with you and it
and it just becomes a real like that
that Mancunian vibe of the night is
which is what we intended to do with a
film the thing for me was filming in a
flicks because a flicks but then is
something different than it was
like at the time it was a social hub it
was it was all about the music and there
was so much life coming out of a flex
and to experience what it was then
now that was a privilege for me please
talk about the music you guys have to
play and sing in the film
don't you worry musicians and singers
beforehand well we know not real I'd
never really picked up a guitar my life
but we've got us together for a good
like five six weeks and and the ad is
rehearsing like three times a week like
make it making it perfect so we were on
an actual Bandemer that by the end of it
money came in the room and it was like
we sound like a [ __ ] manager
Rodi I mean but it did take it would
take on these exact words that words
with lights we keep it down in here
another one next door yeah but knowing
we listen we all learned like a certain
instrument like you know little Gus on a
bass penfold with with maracas or yeah
with nothing yeah threw me out and it
just worked really well like as a group
learning the instruments he was about
trying to get that band rapport yeah
because that's why it's about when
you're in a band it's a brotherhood and
that's what we definitely learned from
that because we helped each other with
the instruments and it was an experience
we're sorry I'm the guitar guy you know
obviously the standing guy he was a real
help as well I've got a shout him out
because he was great it made me look
brilliant listen yeah it's all coming
out here isn't it hey guys so did you
hang out a lot beforehand to get that
kind of bond that you need to portray on
screen because these were talking
lifelong friendships and no matter how
good you are that's something that you
just can't fake so we spent a lot of
time before I'm getting to know each
other and just just just spending time
together and we did it was lucky that we
kind of we clicked straight away and I
think it's quite rare for you know for a
group of five actors to sort of get on
like we did you know I mean because
there's always that that sort of thing
that zealot better than me you know I
mean it is true but it is yeah I mean
and we actually got on like we'd known
each other since we were four years old
and it hopefully it comes across in the
film and yeah hopefully
knows
you